welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video I'm
breaking down a soccer episode 5.
the new episode has a sail barge full of
Easter eggs hidden details and callbacks
to the greater Star Wars lore that make
it a standout in the series that I
really can't wait to talk about somehow
Hayden Christensen returned and a lot of
questions now remain in the air outside
of the plot in the series it's clear
that lucasfilm are really confident
about how big this entry is going to be
and there's been a major push to get
people interested in this episode in
case you don't know they actually held
screenings for the film last night and
it was shown in cinemas across the world
and World Between Worlds like I said
lots of things to talk about and we
build off the back of last week which
has also been traveling into another
galaxy with Morgan and her forces as for
Ahsoka she was forced pushed like it was
a like button and sent over the edge
directly into the water take into the
world Between Worlds she Encantada old
Master Anakin leading to a jaw-dropping
ending
foreign
with a strong focus on the cliffs and
then the shrine that was a big focal
point last week the stones and the
destroyed astrums somewhat resemble a
split World which could be iconography
signaling that Ahsoka is now in the
world Between Worlds might be a reach
but either way surveying the area we see
error reaching out to Carson who at one
point in the episode mentions Senator
Organa this is of course Leia who at the
time would be working alongside the
Senate before she kind of broke off and
then did her own thing we've kind of
seen with the Senate how there's descent
and dismay amongst them and I wouldn't
actually be surprised if it turned out
there were Imperials amongst the ranks
too and the timeline in the show is
something that's been a bit all over the
place but the creative team actually
came out and cleared things up if you've
been following our videos and guess what
turns out I'm a and I got the the
entire timeline completely wrong who
would have thought a YouTuber that
obsesses over movies would be a
idiot well I am but yeah I was under the
impression that this took place after
episode 5 of the Mandalorian season 2.
that capturing Morgan which is when she
was taken off to a New Republic prison
however we now know I was wrong surprise
and that this series actually runs
concurrently with season 3 of the
Mandalorian and that it may even pass it
the further in we get that means Ahsoka
has already been to Luke's Academy in
the book of Boba Fett and that grogu has
currently been reunite with Mando I'm
not sure exactly where the stuff with
the shadow Council takes place because
this line can really be taken one of two
ways Grand Admiral thrawn's return will
Herald in the re-emergence of our
military it could be saying that he's
already returned or they could be
hopeful that he's about to come back
either way just thought I'd clear that
up and yeah let me know below if they've
specified even more of exactly when this
is anyway Jason arrives and he's once
more joined by the Galaxy's worst
babysitter and the Droid Chopper doing
some great parenting we see Hera
allowing him to just wonder about the
Mysterious Island and also get really
close to the Cliff's Edge tell you the
inner dotted me I was saying step away
from them again the hell away from there
another ghost is something that too gets
a lot of focus in this entry and when
inside the cockpit you can actually
catch your photo of Kanan on the
dashboard like a circus flashbacks later
on it kind of reminds them what they're
fighting for and this was actually
kanan's Old Ship he died saving it and
held back an explosion so that Hera and
the crew could get away after they
rescued her from the clutches of the
Empire I wonder if they're gonna explore
him in live action and future stories
with Jason and it'll be interesting to
see whether he's brought into his son
potentially becoming a Jedi in the
future just avoid looks Academy mate
I've heard it's and you
should stay away from it either way I
think we get more hints towards Jason
being in tune throughout this episode as
he's the one who discovers who Yang and
he's also the person that senses ahsokas
in the water which of course eventually
leads to her Discovery now we catch hu
Yang standing there holding sabine's
helmet and this was something we often
saw mandalorians doing to perhaps mourn
the Fallen Boba did it to his father an
attack of the Clones and hu Yang's
devastated that the pair didn't listen
to him from here we go to the title
sequence and at this point we get the
episode's name which is called Shadow
Warrior the Shadow Warrior is actually
someone who's aware of the Unseen parts
of life and they're said to be a person
that can Master their senses and gain
awareness of the world around them
that's something that Ahsoka is gonna
need here as we catch back up with her
in the world Between Worlds Anakin says
that she has to live or die but
initially she refuses to fight him I
won't fight you I've heard that before
now this is actually an Iraq reference
to this I will not fight you father
now the world Between Worlds is a
relatively newly introduced concept that
was first introduced during Star Wars
Rebels Dave filoni said the idea was
inspired by the wood Between Worlds
which came from the Narnia books written
by C.S Lewis in the episode path of the
Jedi we watched Ezra unlock it by
figuring out the puzzles with the hands
on the Morris God murals Ezra ended up
putting his hand on the daughter and in
the end this gave him access to the
dimension now Ahsoka ended up burning
her hand trying to grab the star map
last time and this is likely how she was
able to journey into the other realm now
what it is gets a little bit complicated
but it is something that the Jedi have
known about for Millennia appearing in
the sacred Jedi texts on the Temple of
akatu bless you it allowed someone to
step into a dimension that existed
outside of both time and space I don't
know how deep you are into Marvel made
because I don't know yet but let's
assume yeah let's assume if you're
watching this video you're a dork
foreign
that we have the Multiverse but in
between the universes we have a realm
that connects them which you have to
pass through as a barrier in order to
get from one Universe to the next that's
not exactly how the world Between Worlds
works but the principle is the same with
it being something within the fabric of
time and space that gives you access to
everything I know there's lots of
confusion with multiverses and other
universes and galaxies but it's also
important to bear in mind that this
isn't necessarily a Marvel multiversal
situation we're not going to get Darth
Vader for example popping up with David
prowse's voice and stuff
apart
I want them alive and we're not going to
be getting different versions of
characters it's just a an element
outside of time and space during the
world between world's first appearance
we saw as Ezra actually saved Ahsoka
from a battle with Darth Vader pulling
her out of time she was able to survive
the encounter and continue past it when
in the past she hadn't that makes sense
anyway after saving herb radio wish to
also save his master Kanan but she
talked him out of it due to what Jairus
sacrificed his life for now they went to
close the portal to the world Between
Worlds which is when they realized that
Emperor Palpatine was trying to access
it they managed to escape and then shut
it down stopping the dark lord from
having complete control over everything
and when discussing what's going on here
Henry Gilroy said that the world Between
Worlds will appear slightly different
for everyone else like the cave on
dagobar it's what you bring into it that
affects certain things and your
connection to the force will manifest
differently for example with Ezra we saw
as wolves surrounded the doorway and
here anakins pulled across because he
was ahsoka's Master it's also important
to bear in mind that the doorways of the
world between worlds are linked about
Jedi and Sith temples now MD actually
pointed out that Vader's Castle Mustafar
was built to be a conduit and that in
issue 25 of his solo comic he stepped
through this barrier in order to try and
save Padme there are ways to replay the
past in the Star Wars universe but
fortunately this can often talk you on
instead of actually helping them now the
pair joke about aging which will not
make any de-aging jokes because I
actually thought that the CGI this
episode was really well done however
this idea of Aging slightly foreshadows
the younger and older versions that we
get of both characters throughout now we
will talk about that later on but at the
moment he says he's here to finish her
training this is something Luke wanted
to do with Yoda and Return of the Jedi
but unfortunately he was one of the only
Jedi we've ever met that actually seemed
to dive natural causes now this is
Anakin in his Revenge of the Sith era
and he has the same outfit and scar on
his eye busting at his blue lightsaber
this event she turns to red but here
he's very much in the fighting stance
that he had during Revenge of the Sith
twirling it around he pulls off several
of the moves that he did against Obi-Wan
in their first duel now both Anakin and
ahsoka's lightsaber colors are the same
colors as the world Between Worlds blue
and white Pathways and it adds such a
cool visual Dynamic to the entire scene
at the 5 minute 47 Mark you also get a
subtle sense of what's happening is the
frames split evenly by one of the
pathways to symbolize the pass riff
between them Soca ended up walking away
from the Jedi Order unless this is
almost like writing the wrongs of the
past Anakin was last seen the timeline
at the end of Return of the Jedi with
his Force ghost appearing directly to
Luke played by Sebastian Shaw originally
this was swapped out for Hayden
Christensen in the later special
editions to fit more in line with the
prequels Lucas said it was because
that's when Anakin was good but yeah he
did kind of redeem himself at the end
when Luke removed his helmet but moving
on either way canonically it makes sense
that he'd appear to a circle like this
because that's how she last remembers
him to be even Easter in by calling her
Snips which was a nickname that he used
to have for her the two are greatly
linked and even the Clone Wars then with
them looking looking wistfully after
coming across the Venezuela Anna circus
lightsaber amongst the wreckage of the
conflict this symbolizes all the Death
destruction and loss had really been for
nothing because as pops was manipulating
both sides really hit you with a loss
and it was such a devastating moment
that I'm kind of glad we at least get
some closure on here now back on the
surface Jason Taps further into his
feelings saying that he can sense a suck
around the water Chopper wouldn't be
able to pick this up because it's not
technically the water itself but we know
from last week how she was able to go
somewhat Beyond it Jason seems strongly
connected at the force and he even has
the wisdom to silence himself and listen
out for nature unlike Rebels the world
Between Worlds doesn't have any doorways
like we saw and there's a stationary to
what's going on at this moment a Jason
and Hera can still sense them though and
they can hear the lightsaber blades
amongst all the waves now back in the
battle we see Anakin outsmarting Ahsoka
and he does this by destroying the
environment this is something he'd often
do in fights such as throwing stuff at
Luke in Empire and cutting pipes when he
was going against Dooku Anakin giving
Osaka the option to love her die also
has ties in with tales of the Jedi as
the episode of her birth was called life
and death now huge it out to add x-star
thunderx and Twitter for dropping a
great theory about what's going on with
Anakin they believe that he's actually a
Morris God and there are certain ways
that this could line up we have seen
Morris guards in the Saga before and
there was a big Arc involving a
character known as the sun and also
Anakin Skywalker the sun was similar to
Palpatine in that he was too trying to
get Anakin to join the Dark Side and he
showed him images of the future namely
padme's death this show that no matter
what Anakin was always going to be
tempted with the dark side and though he
overcame the sun he still got hit with
another plan and the sun was a God that
was holding everything together and they
were also joined by the father and
daughter which ties in with the soccer
the soccer actually died at one point
with their daughter's energy being
brought across in order to revive her
Fedora also somewhat manifested in Mirai
AKA ahsoka's owl who actually appeared
in the world Between Worlds huge it out
to Mt for doing an insane breakdown
going over all this and also his theory
about how Anakin maybe a manifestation
of the sun simply disguised as him
either way whether that happens or not I
think going forward we're gonna see
Anakin taking the sun's place with
Ahsoka potentially taking over the role
of the daughter though the master of
serpent fan art shows Marek in the sun's
place I think there may be another
character instead who who could take
over this role now we may see the
rebuilding of the Trinity and this is
something that's been laced throughout
the entire series for example there were
three figures at the night's sister
Temple and they all had their hands in
similar positions to the mortise Gods
the triquetra is also a symbol
synonymous with the Trinity and thus it
seems like the series deeply linked to
this with us potentially getting a third
figure this could possibly be bailin and
that would actually tie back to him
talking about how reaching thrawn will
open up access to a great power now
bailen's name May sign with the sun too
but not necessarily how we typically
understand it the name balin's skull
actually riffs from The Wolf of Norse
mythology who as we know from the
Legends would chase after the sun this
Sun could mean the sun here and this
would still be true from a certain point
of view now balen destroyed the
Airstream last week which itself
resembled a burning star AKA a son tying
this all together maybe a reach but if
you are interested in more of these
ideas then definitely check out Auntie's
video on the channel right now guys
getting shouted out by places like den
of geek and yeah you just just killing
it out of the channel at the moment and
I know people are very interested in his
theories I see them getting brought up
in other videos as well and yeah the
guy's head is just it's just on a
completely another level now we don't
have a sponsor this week but I thought
you know what we can sponsor ourselves
like some losers and let you know that
we have an Ahsoka and grago inspired
t-shirt available on our shop below the
video we also have a wide range of nerdy
merch there too including our few time
t-shirts and heavy spoilers logo stuff
Anakin cuts out the pathway they're on
which sends Ahsoka hurling into the past
here we see a younger version of her
with Anakin returning in his Clone Wars
outfit
yeah no kidding this comes with shoulder
pads and also a neck piece which
somewhat foreshadows what he'd wear
under the cape as Darth Vader I think
the dhing in this episode is brilliant
and and after last week yeah I was a bit
worried that it would look fake and
uncanny valerie-ish however Anakin looks
brilliant and dear me this is the best
de-aging I've ever seen on Ahsoka
because she look she looks about 15
years old now now this is actually
Ariana Greenblatt and if you recognize
her this is because she appeared during
Avengers Infinity War playing a younger
Gamora this is actually the actress
Thanos took under his wing after wiping
out half her people now he can catch a
clone trooper transport and Ahsoka also
busts out her original green lightsaber
I'm actually doing a video on Return of
the Jedi at the moment and green
lightsabers were actually invented for
that film because the blue got lost
against the sky of Tatooine during the
opening act over on the posters you can
see that Luke originally had a blue one
showing that this was indeed the
original plan for the film either way
post battle we see a song attend to the
wounded and can also catch Captain Rex
in the background talking to some
Twilights a Captain Rex is actually a
clone trooper that was first introduced
during the Clone Wars series a major
Ally of Ahsoka he actually worked
alongside her during Order 66 though
ordered by Palpatine directly to kill
her he managed to overcome his
programming and kill two of his brothers
in order to protect his friend they
managed to stop the ship from taking
over control and both managed to escape
the order which is when they fled out
into the Galaxy now as some of the
Clones managed to overcome this
naturally and we saw this in the likes
of the bad batch who didn't succumb to
it the Rex showed back up in Rebels
along with a couple of other clones who
managed to get away from the Empire Rex
is once more voiced by Tamira Morrison
no you have to know that he's being
played by a different actor and you also
get both his phase one and Phase 2 armor
with several scenes including him
riffing off the Clone Wars this includes
ryloth and also the siege of Mandalore
the former was a major conflict during
the war and Rex is one of the connected
characters to Ahsoka so it makes sense
that he'd be pulled into this along with
the Anakin who she of course also
encounters nice little detail in the
credits as well and they actually call
him Commander slash Captain Rex because
one battle takes place during ryloth and
one on the siege of Mandalore which is
when he got his promotion so that's why
he's got two names really really good
attention to detail there now with
Anakin they talk about how this wall
wasn't what she trained for and this is
very much what the Jedi base their
teachings around Lucas looked at Eastern
self-defense techniques and what they
would do in order to develop the Jedi
when he was making the first movies are
really not supposed to be Warriors as
soldiers they're supposed to be
peacekeepers that never go on the attack
this is something Mace Windu said and it
shows how much the Jedi lost their way
during this war Jedi are always supposed
to act in self-defense with the Sith
being those that would tap into their
anger and then go on the attack this is
why all of Yoda is training to Luke is
about running and sensing nature and
it's also why ahsoka's reject acting
being Warrior here now he tells if he
stops fighting then they'll die and we
see him and what I think is the 50 First
arming up to take the fight to ryloth
now during this we get one of the
coldest shots I've ever seen in Star
Wars as Anakin walks through the fog
which is when he switches to Vader this
is something that we've somewhat seen in
the Saga before and during Rebels
Palpatine switched between his Senator
luck and then Darth Sidious now there
were rumors that a circle would actually
play the battle with Obi-Wan and Anakin
on Mustafar with her taking the place of
Kenobi this would show that things could
have played out differently but
ultimately they ended up the way that
they did we don't know why this was Kurt
but in the end it seems like they
decided to go against it and potentially
the scene just didn't work that well
sometimes the concept script and film
something and then upon shooting or
editing it it might not hit and people
just think the episode works better
without it either way this would see
Apprentice versus Master and the newly
Chris Invader would be a way for a Circa
to accept that the past is the past and
it can't really be changed now it's also
possible that the leaks weren't right
and this was never in it but making Star
Wars who leaked it got a number of big
things right about the series so far so
I kind of want to give them the benefit
of the doubt and just accept what
they've said which is that the scene was
cut anyway back on the surface we see is
an X-Wing sweepsie area with Hera saying
people don't vanish out of thin air who
Yang says no well normally no and this
could be him referring to Obi-Wan Kenobi
and how he vanished in thin air which
empty noticed when we were watching the
episode together Hera also talks about
how they're out here Chasing Ghosts
which could reference not only Ahsoka
but also their mission to find Ezra go
back to Ahsoka and we see a now fighting
using her double lightsabers this is a
live-action Recreation of the siege of
Mandalore which was a big moment in the
Clone Wars series oh here we see a
circle taking down some live-action
Mandalorian super Commandos which in the
series were led by Darth Maul this is
why they have horns as it was a tribute
to the current wielder of the darksaber
and unfortunately though he doesn't pop
up but Ahsoka is wearing the same outfit
from the final season of the show how
soccer again refuses to fight and at
this point she instead crosses her arms
joined by Anakin we get a classic moment
that calls back to the show with a pair
standing side by side Anakin seems to be
teaching Ahsoka how to keep fighting in
order to survive even though he might
not want to I feel like he wants Ahsoka
to stop him seeing as only the evil man
he became but all says the good and wise
Jedi Knight that he used to be however
we see him going evil or with his eyes
turning like how they did in Revenge of
the Sith when he went on the attack we
also get a further call back to that
movie with his back being turned like
how it was in the film that fight was
Master versus Apprentice which this
battle also is as well now leads to
another epic lightsaber Jewel with a
music pulling the same Notes From The
Jewel of fate
[Music]
pushed back to the bridge we now hear
Vader's breathing and when Anakin says
you lack conviction you can also hear a
voice modulator to make him sound more
like his older self now it's such a cool
battle and I love the way that this
whole thing progressed Anakin was here
to make her into a warrior but he's
forced to fight for her life which in
the end ends up saving her we see her
eyes almost go sit as well but she
refuses to go down that dark path which
eventually leads into her transformation
we see this with Anakin 2 as his eyes
turn back to normal and there's some
more Echoes the redemptionaki went on
now I feel like they're digging into
what Anakin's Redemption really means
here and how though he was destined to
fall he was always destined to redeem
himself no matter what happened Anakin
was unfortunately born a slave and they
would always hit a point where he was
enslaved once more either by Palpatine
the son of someone else even in the
Clone Wars we saw as the father actually
saw him as something more than mortal
you have a very simple view of the
universe
[Music]
nor Jedi
I am much more
and so are you where news reached me
that the chosen one had been found
I needed to see for myself so we know
that I was always the ark that he would
go on that would take him directly here
the world between Wells and sends to
water and I love the effect on this
transformation such a cool way to
represent it with Ahsoka somewhat being
baptized and then born again after she's
pulled out of the water she eventually
goes and become a Soaker the white this
is something that the creative team
talked about through the week and they
basically went into her this entire
series is built up to Osaka becoming a
sucker the white they stated they were
influenced by the transition that
Gandalf had during the two towers and in
that we watched him change from Gandalf
the Gray into Gandalf the White this
came after he traveled into an extra
Dimension and this itself allowed him to
be reborn the team behind the show said
they were kind of Reckoning the ending
of rebels in which Ahsoka showed up in a
white cloak and that the transformation
was instead gonna be happening in this
series this is why this shot for shot
remake of the ending of rebels had a
circle and a great cloak rather than the
white that she originally appeared in
this will be the next step of their
evolution rather than it happening in
Rebels and it'll be something that she
needs in order to fully take on drawn in
all his cronies Lucas also based The
Return of the Jedi title on Return of
the King so there are these links to
Lord of the Rings lace throughout the
Saga you can also see her getting pulled
out the water being similar to Frodo
pulling some out of it too and yeah in
the end it's sort of like poetry they
rhyme on the ship she's grabbed by
Brennan Wayne's character and he's
actually an actor that plays Mando in
the suit most of the time Pedro vices
him of course but a lot of the time it's
actually Brandon went on set so I'm glad
that they at least had him doing
something where he got to show his face
now Jason senses that they saved her
without even getting it confirmed now he
watches he rests up on the ship kinda
wish they just kept the headpiece on
that that hides the joins because yeah
to me it looked a bit weird but if you
disagree yeah let me know below
Unfortunately they haven't found Sabine
yet and they need a Circa to explain
exactly what's going on Osaka uses
forced Telemetry once again like
calcastis and this allows her to sense
what's happened with Sabine learning the
fleeter on their way to Robbie caught
Marshall them we hear him on Mothman
needs evidence of thrawn in order for
the claims to seem legit a throne coming
back is a major thing that could reshape
the Galaxy and unite the Empire before
it becomes the first order we know that
there has to be a factor that brings
them all together and at this point the
shadow councils working in the shallows
I think judging by what they said
project necromancy is still in its
project infancy and this thrawn is
needed to be the one who's gonna come
and change things up both Mano season 3
and this have demonstrated that Rebel
Imperials are in every aspect of the new
Republic but they still need that leader
to inspire them to step out the Shadows
this needs to be someone they feel can
turn the tide unless I think thrawn's
gonna represent that before we get snoke
and kylo now Ahsoka decides to hop in a
pear girl's mouth and the Pinocchio plan
will hopefully lead them to where Morgan
and Cohen off to also the way that the
teeth close around the ship it kind of
reminded me of the space slug from
Empire Strikes Back Ahsoka trusts
completely in the force to guide the
pergol to berettiere and the old Galaxy
Travelers used to have to rely on them
before nav computers were developed so
which would then show them the way it's
a beautiful scene and it kind of Rifts
on the end of rebels in which Ezra was
taken away during the Battle of lothal
we saw Ezra sacrificing himself in order
to defeat thrawn and take him to a
galaxy far far away so he could no
longer harm those in this one in a
series there were thoughts had a
counter-attack would come but it never
did and then we got a time Jump to post
Battle of Endor which is when Sabine in
Ahsoka went looking for Ezra now we see
is the fleet arrived with tiva buying
time for Ahsoka to then commune with the
pergol this allows her to travel with
the Pod and escape the planet and then
go off into pots and known it's an epic
way to close things out and Ahsoka
promises that she's gonna find them all
her I'll find them
foreign
as for my thoughts on the series so far
I actually think right that they've
managed to improve week on week and that
the show is to its credit getting better
and better I don't think it's any secret
that I was one of the early reactors
that said I was disappointed in the
first two episodes and that was due to
their pacing and the whole chasing and
MacGuffin thing though elements of that
are still in place I feel the series has
got better week by week and that they
really found their footing recently in
terms of what to do with these
characters they've brought the more
interesting elements of rebels into live
action and also you know just seeing
Anakin back it does elevate the series
for me know where things go from here we
don't fully know but there has been
Nixon rumors about where we could be
heading for the next part of the video
I'm going to be discussing what said to
be happening with thrawn and how it
leaves things off so if you don't want
to know turn off now yeah you still you
are still here though okay I can tell
you here uh so yeah we're going to talk
about all that and kind of not do
massive spoilers but delve into where
things are going to be going and how the
show is going to wrap up so apparently
it's going to end with thrawn actually
winning and then we'll get the feeling
that darkness is falling on the Galaxy
however there will also be a tease that
there's something even worse than him
out there which is how we're gonna close
things off in the series now because of
this a lot of people have been going
wild with you times but I actually think
it'll probably end up being palp soon we
of course know will somehow be returning
for Rise of Skywalker just seems that's
the more straightforward thing as I
think Anakin will probably just stick to
pretty much being in the world Between
Worlds rather than out in the Galaxy
either way let me know I told you it
wasn't massive spoilers but yeah let me
know your thoughts below and where you
think the series is gonna go in the
future please drop a like on the video
and if you want to support the Channel
with a bit of cash then air please
become a member of the spoiler Society
by clicking the join button below it
really means a lot and as a thank you'll
get early access to videos every week as
as it's just our way to say yeah thanks
for thanks for all your support now if
you want something else to watch you got
some videos on screen right now where
we're either talking about the Aquaman
and the lost King official teaser
trailer or just Starship troopers from
1997 definitely recommend that last one
you know we go fully deep on just all
the layers in that film and yeah
hopefully I see you over there right
after this out of the way thanks for
saying through the video I hope you
enjoy the rest of your week I've been
Paul and you've been the best peace